E aí
[Música]
nós estamos aqui hoje para vos falar da
nossa experiência em setembro do ano
passado nós apresentamos uma queixa
contra 33 governos no tribunal europeu
dos direitos humanos por não estarem a
fazer o suficiente para combater as
alterações climáticas essa falta de ação
pois nossos direitos e os todos os
jovens e crianças do mundo em risco
entre as Gerais estamos a pedir ao
tribunal que declare precisamente isto
que a falta de ação apropriada em
matéria de alterações climáticas
constitui uma violação dos direitos
fundamentais se tribunal nos de razão
esse 33 traduz vão ter de respeitar no
fundo aconteceu acordo de Paris passasse
a servir coletivo para eles e e seria A
Extraordinário a partir da semente
qualquer cidadão destes países poderia
usar a decisão que esperamos obter para
exigir medidas concretas no seu contexto
específico
e o processo de resposta por parte do
tribunal europeu dos Direitos Humanos
costuma ser bastante demorado mas para
nossa surpresa em outubro recebemos luz
verde do tribunal que aceitou o nosso
caso tendo em conta a urgência da ação
climática em novembro o caso foi
comunicado aos 33 países que responderam
mês passado vindo ao tribunal que
repensasse a decisão de considerar o
caso como prioritário este pedido foi
negado pelo tribunal O que é um sinal
extremamente positivo a nossa esperança
é obviamente ganhar o caso o que
significa Será que os países terão de
tomar medidas para cumprir as metas do
acordo de Paris o que terá não só
imensos benefícios para o nosso planeta
mas também será um ótimo ponto de
partida para a resolução desta crise
climática que ameaçam o nosso futuro o
nosso não está bem Estamos preocupados
companhia mas também com as alterações
climáticas as outras sistemáticas sobre
problemas que acontecem Salmo
o resultado dos nossos Actos diários e
que não seja alguma vacina Além disso
todos os dias vemos a biodiversidade
destinguir neste momento já podemos mais
no caso da fauna de forma impossível
seguiu-se hoje eu também não sabia sobre
algo que o tempo está em choque com
açúcar com isso aconteceu com a
inscrição no jogo de dominó conhecer o
Efeito Dominó queria fiz baleias ninguém
não podemos cuidar a superfície do mar e
é geralmente ou menos que o ponto tem
que logo menos peixe e menos perigosa
retirado da atmosfera agora pense no
nosso de águia cada vez mais alguns
notícias de tempo instável em incêndios
aterrorizadores ficou longe vezes pelos
a crescerem se governos não cumprirem o
acordo de Paris e não ouvir os
cientistas e nós vamos continuar a bater
recorde Absoluto em nosso planeta
torna-se mais o estilo ao mesmo tempo
nós vamos escrever de qualidade de vida
pois é muito do que os nossos pais e
avós tiveram sucesso e perdemos a
oportunidade de ter um susto e como nós
não temos que isso aconteça vamos
a continuar a agir em lutar pelo nosso
futuro nos últimos 20 anos porque ela
teve oito dos dez anos mais quentes
deste a riscos
eu estou muito fora há provas de que as
alterações climáticas estão a causar
problemas de todos os tipos e os
cientistas já disseram vezes e vezes tem
conta que mundo tem de agir com urgência
para podermos evitar o pior
a todos os dias somos bombardeados com
números sobre as alterações climáticas
alentejo vai ter mais de 80 dias por ano
corro riscos extremos de incêndios as
vagas de calor podem causar quatro vezes
mais até 30 dias no final deste século
podem morrer trinta vezes mais pessoas
por causa do calor extremo do que o
início de século se realmente pensarmos
nestes números eles são assustadores mas
não deixam de ser isso números e é muito
difícil por números em perspectiva
Especialmente quando os ouvimos repetir
repetir duas vezes e vezes sem conta por
estarmos constantemente ouvir as mesmas
histórias que não me dizem grande parte
de extensibilidade deste tema vamos
tentando fazer pequenas mudanças Como
reciclar e usar transportes públicos mas
sabemos que sozinhos não podemos
resolver o problema
e isso pode ser extremamente frustrante
não fomos nós causámos as alterações
climáticas sabemos tive caminho atual
nos pode salvar o futuro mas não temos
poder individualmente para realmente
mudar o rumo mas em conjunto e com as
medidas decisivas dos governos essa
essas mudanças podem acontecer às
alterações climáticas mas sem com a
nossa cabeça eu sei que isso acontece a
pessoas de qualquer idade Mas penso que
as crianças e os jovens estão numa
situação emocional particularmente
difícil por um lado que sentimos uma
enorme pressão para salvarmos o planeta
em todo o lado ouvimos que as gerações
mais jovens são a esperança vamos fazer
a diferença vamos resolver tudo porque
não nos contentamos com a situação que
nos entregaram porque foi mesmo isso que
aconteceu as planeta já chegou as nossas
mãos doente mas é em nós que nos esperam
encontrar a cura por outro lado sem
temos que muitas as pessoas mais velhas
não tem a consciência que nós
e para muito a pena mais um grau para
nós pode significar aplicar muitos
sonhos e talvez até do direito mais
fundamental de todos o direito à Vida e
portanto dizemos que vemos é voltar para
a escola que as nossas manifestações são
uma desculpa de preguiçosos que não
temos direito de protestar Mas não
sabemos nada sobre a vida beijão bem o
que é viver entre essas duas expressões
e com a consciência plena de que as
consequências das alterações climáticas
só vão tornar-se cada vez mais
devastadores e recorrentes a menos que
as coisas mudem muito às vezes é como se
tivéssemos presos entre um passado que
não Vivemos em um futuro que não nos
deixam divertir
e eu pergunto me diariamente e se nada
for feito em que condições vamos viver
no futuro alguns de vocês se calhar já
estão a suspirar e a pensar ou não
através de alterações climáticas já não
posso ouvir falar deste assunto e eu
percebo é muito difícil lidar com este
problema por um lado por Parece que
ainda é tudo muito distante que ainda
falta muito tempo e que se calhar não se
justifica fazer tanto barulho Mas isso é
uma ilusão a cada ano que passa mais
pessoas ficam sem casa sem comida sem a
própria vida por causas relacionadas com
as alterações climáticas e o pior não
está assim tão longe em 2100 a minha
irmã vai ter 88 anos é muito doloroso
pensar que podemos perder o nosso lar a
nossa saúde tanto daquilo que nos é
querido é mais fácil fechar um bocadinho
os olhos negar a realidade eu próprio às
vezes faço isso tenho Dizem que quando
esquecer o assunto como se fosse um
mecanismo de defesa mas essa ligação não
nos ajuda individualmente
e ativamente nos ajuda encontro
comunidade quando nós tenta ansioso
frustrado revoltado com as alterações
climáticas mas não consegue ver a mesma
preocupação a sua volta é uma solidão
tremenda esta é que a ansiedade que
sentimos constantemente é altamente
prejudicial para a nossa saúde mental
esses sentimentos todos negativos vamos
gastando devagarinho vamos deixando cada
vez mais vulneráveis como canismo ficou
bem sempre utilizei uma tempo livre para
passar na para passear na natureza para
me sentir menos ansiosa mas isso não
chega Se nada mudar em breve não vamos
ter da natureza para nos ajudar a gerir
as nossas emoções
e com a Catarina a Cláudia o André e o
Martin me disseram o tempo está a passar
muito depressa e precisamos agir agora
nós temos maneiras diferentes de sentir
as alterações climáticas mas concordamos
de uma coisa a única maneira de vida há
coisas pressões estes medos a sociedade
é arregaçar as mangas e fazer o possível
para mudar o rumo o Dalai Lama uma vez
disso se vocês acham que o bicho muito
pequeno incomoda sentido e com uma mel
da minha tenda pois nós somos desse
bicho muito tempo que incomoda muito
nosso próprio Lar esse é o nosso planeta
já Luís Vaz de Camões que se tava isso
quando estava as três Lusíadas sabiam
mas infelizmente dia após dia ver se a
terra a pessoa luz a sua vida seus belos
rios e suas grandes florestas ver seus
animada desaparecer e as questões
naturais a causar destruição
e quando isso acontece as plantas volts
nossos corações e ficamos com os olhos
seis de um dinheiro que não deixa ver
nosso Tour Mas calma sei que isto parece
horrível e não ter soluções e Vocês
perguntam como é que ele já voltei isto
está se eu começar a agir agora vou
conseguir mudar alguma coisa nós temos
três essa esperança de volta se nos
juntarmos todos jovens e adultos uma só
voz a pedir vamos agir e mudar as
alterações climáticas ainda vamos a
Tempo de Mudar de agir e corrigir os
erros da humanidade ainda vamos a tempo
de mostrar aos nossos filhos e as
gerações futuras a presa que vimos e
sentimos em crianças estão sem seus pais
te levar levantar do sofá e gritar todos
juntos até mesmo vocês que estão aí
Evaristo Ei estamos aqui vejam que
nossas vozes já estão a ter impactos foi
neste momento o tribunal europeu dos
direitos humanos e sim uma resposta por
parte dos 33 países europeus até final
de Maio
e tenta pedir ao tribunal que me ajuda a
obter desgovernos ações concretas que
vão melhorar e corrigir o mal que foi
feito por isso Pedimos que agende
conosco a várias organizações não
governamentais portuguesas que já
manifestaram o seu apoio como por
exemplo a free Force Future e Perry
fornecer 36 e junte-se a nós porque nós
precisamos essa força conjunta vocês
contam conosco e nós contamos convosco
como afzer juntos somos mais fortes e
nosso negócio ficaram mais poderosas e
[Música]